nowhere the severed head of a past
Celestial in the comics nowhere was
killed by the sibio deity no but since
the Symbiotes seem like Sony properties
some believe that the MCU version of
these events could be that nowhere died
in the past war against the celestial's
creators so yeah we gotta go up a rung
higher and to do that we gotta look at
the new origin described in the ultimate
Volume 2 number 6 in 2017 actually
published right as Marvel Studios was
beginning seriously developing this
eternals film in this updated mythology
in the beginning there was the first
firmament the very first living
embodiment of the original Universe
before eternity even and out of
loneliness the first firmament created
beings he called The aspirants Who then
created beneath them multi-colored
Rebels that we know as the celestials
and everybody went to war from this
eternity was formed maybe an aspirin
killed nowhere and then within eternity
Irish celestials were left to fiddle
with their flesh puppets on Earth
[Music]